has had her appeal dismissed by the
court behind me Mr Justice J has decided
to dismiss her Appeal on all counts this
was an appeal to try and regain her
British citizenship it means that Shamir
begum will not be able to win back her
British passport it leaves her now very
much in limbo this was the 15 year old
school girl that left East London Bound
for is controlled Syria in 2015. this
appealed dismissal sides essentially
with the government's argument that yes
even if somebody has been brainwashed or
has gone to Syria they still pose a
national threat risk and a risk to
National Security this dismisses the
arguments that were put forward by Ms
bagan's lawyers that she was a victim of
child trafficking